on this episode we talk about landing
pages Nintendo and shitty social media
experts
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 106 of the askgaryvee
show all right guys get back to work
relax I mean if it goes so quiet geez
alright India let's get into the show
really good shot David asks if you were
going to be on TV and you could only
promote one platform to be followed on
which one would it be
David tremendous question the answer
would be I would reverse engineer the
audience of the show one of the biggest
reasons I think that I've had success as
a communicator is I'm not religious
about what I have to say at that moment
I'm religious about what does the
audience on the other side need or want
to hear if I was them using the empathy
radar and so if I met at USC I'm gonna
throw on a guru shirt as a hahaha and
really just jam on how do I bring them
value like if I'm a real if I really
took entrepreneur class like let me
prove to you that you shouldn't be in
that class going be an entrepreneur
right if I'm on TV and I'm on CNN or fox
or CNBC I need to hit the masses that's
gonna be a third you know it's gonna be
everybody but 35 to 75 so I would answer
Facebook in that environment cuz it's
gonna reach the most potential people
but if I'm on the youngest skewing show
I can think I don't know some sort of
show that's targeting 15 to 20 year-olds
though they're not watching TV anymore
but let's say you know if I was on a
youtube show talking then I would
probably Drive snapchat as the one
platform probably Instagram actually if
I'm gonna fully fully answered I
probably Instagram and so to me it's
it's I'm answering you and one of the
interesting things is I mean I really
got into the community this weekend the
kids were playing around in the backyard
I had a lot of pockets to like kind of
check out my phone I engaged a little
bit big shout out to a lot of you a lot
of you saw me jumping into your facebook
comments it was interesting to see how
people are analyzing the show and I want
to say back to me listening I want to
say if you just watch the way I answered
that question I'm trying to bring as
much value across the board to everybody
I answered the question its Facebook
it's snapchat but I also want people to
understand it's reverse engineering the
audience that's listening in everywhere
environment in every interview with ink
magazine in every TV show and every I'm
in Ireland you know I'm in the Middle
America if you know if I'm in Alabama I
curse a little less because cursing is
not as great in the Bible Belt you know
like you know and so but if I'm in
Brooklyn you know two sixteen year olds
I'm gonna bring it and so uh you know
that's that Chris asks do you think that
the Nintendo and actually on Android
would be a bit bizarre feels like
Nintendo might not want to invest so
heavily in home consoles anymore thanks
Mike
Chris a great question sorry to randomly
jump into your question and answer it
but that's what we do on the askgaryvee
show you know I don't think panel first
of all Nintendo should be concerned or
and should not bet on just being a home
counsel because there's no such thing
anymore that's like being a TV provider
and only caring about the TV set in a
world where this is the number one
device in our society and so I would
argue it's about time Nintendo where
have you been for the last forty eight
months Mario because you've been wasting
your time away as other people have been
jumping in there should be no Angry
Birds that should have been princess
from Zelda but no Nintendo was slow and
old and to Nintendo's credit wants a
playing card company in a way back
uh-huh look history lesson for the kids
Nintendo needs to pivot again and start
acting 2016-17 and so if they're betting
on being a home council or holding on
like oh there's still a place for home
councils they're completely out of their
goddamn mind cuz everything's going on
over the top of a television set and so
to me it's not like weird
shouldn't they be worried about that
it's a weird where the hell have you
been
Paul asks do you recommend your
website's landing page be a jab like a
blog or a right hook Paul you're welcome
for all I do the answer to your question
the answer to your question is you know
I think it depends on what your business
is doing and so to me if you're selling
something you need to have some level of
right hook because you just have such
infinite amounts of time when people
land but if you're selling information
or you're looking at brand awareness or
you've been so silly as an organization
for such a long time you need a
countermove to soften your right hooks
and that's it and that's the theme of
106 episodes which is that every and
different it's a reason I can give away
my best advice here have all my
competitors and other agencies and other
things coming I mean I had a bunch of
competitors literally small Manor medius
asking me for advice over the weekend an
email which I was answering because at
the end of the day I can give my best
advice because it's all in theory right
it's all in theory I can give this kind
of detail which is pretty significant
but then you still got to get into one
extra later the clients of Maine are the
things that I work on have to get to one
extra layer of detail to be successful
and so to me it I'd have to audit what
the business or organization was doing
for the last 12 24 36 months if it
existed and then I need to understand
what it needs to achieve but once you
understand what you're trying to achieve
all your behavior has to match that and
that's why a strategy a religion a
belief system is so imperative in what
you do the amount of people that are
watching this show right now that are
wishy-washy on what they're trying to
achieve caring about dumb [ __ ] like oh I
want a nice watch or a car like you're
gonna lose if you understand how to
level that up I can get any watch in any
car I want because I leveled up and I
still don't want that [ __ ] and so
I'm not judging you you do you you do
what you want but I promise you push
yourself to understanding what you're
doing at one to three levels higher and
you'll amass that success along the way
that are beneath you if you want that
thing right in front of you if you go
above it that thing is a byproduct of
you shooting for a higher plane so thing
comes down to the details Matthew asks
why is it that people who specialize in
social media never have a clear cut
social media brand except twenty links
Matthew Matthew Matthew Roth thank you
so much for asking this question to the
world that I just jumped into and and
rode into the show
I agree 1,000% I'm flabbergasted as
somebody who wrote a book called the
Thank You economy that talked about
engagement and all the social media this
was 2011 where I was definitely supply
and demand wise at the top of a pyramid
of social media experts like to think I
still end but I like separating myself
by actually putting in the work it was
stunning to me how many people like
carry me that was the best book you're
so right you're so right
and I jump in look they can reply to
anybody like all they do is go around
and just share links trying to build up
the literally plate I want to talk about
not understanding the game that matters
literally their behavior was caring
about how many followers they had you
want talk about an action I will never
care about its how many top-line
potential awareness I have with I care
about the depth I care about the 24
people that jumped on this last week and
watch 40 episodes and really care and
really intrigue and see some value
that's what I care about it's about
depth
2424 people that's how much I get
excited about it in a world where people
wanna I'm gonna get to 10,000 I'm gonna
get to a hundred thousand a lot of
social media professionals share a
crapload of content because it gets
retweeted and that's how they get
followers not recognizing what does that
behavior towards I mean just to remind
the market I was you know what I did by
speaking about the future social media
that it was it allowed me to build a
business allowed me to build a
foundation off that thought leadership
and it was a clear Club plan right it
wasn't like super like oh like how do we
get here Oh weird how we how do we get
here no wasn't any of that
it was understanding that my behavior
had a map what I wanted to happen and by
the way even this in itself in five
years when you watch something that I
put out will make sense that this wasn't
even the end goal the end goal is not to
build 100 million dollar your agency and
so I think the reason they suck is
because they suck I think the reason
that a lot of social media professionals
suck is because I think a lot of real
estate agents and a lot of SEO experts
and a lot of like whatever is hot let me
jump on it people jump on social media
because nobody knew what the hell it was
and there's a lot of players who jump
ahead of things that nobody understands
and tries to collect fast nickels and
pennies
during that indecisive gray period
instead of looking for the long dollars
or the long Benjamins as P Diddy and bi
G may rest in peace
Stefon he used to say and Lil Kim I like
the way she used to say it your big
little Kim fan in the air like tell me
what you feel when you hear the word Lil
Kim
Oh like queen bee like queen yeah
Oh left I talk Sheldon I was giving my
left that was my little that was my it
was a little left i doc Sheldon I love
doc he's been pounding me doc I
apologize I don't have to answer
something for you I'm like insane in the
membrane on my email like worst all-time
like I'm so humbled by the attempt
you're getting 500 emails a second hurts
your left eye doc Sheldon asks if you
could instantly trade one of your
weaknesses for one of your strengths
which two would you trade this is one of
the great questions ever this is really
good I don't want to like I don't want
to I'm scared to screw this up which is
probably why I'm giving it some thought
so d-roc stefan find some jeopardy like
music that doesn't get me sued as I
pondered this and talk this out
a strength into a weakness what am I
really strong at that I don't think is
so needed God I love myself so much that
I don't want to change anything this is
why I'm struggling with this this talks
about the level of happiness I have
what's a weakness that I can't I gotta I
really
so first and foremost the answer to the
question is there's no absolute here
this is more like 80/20 where maybe I
would switch it from an 80/20 to a 2080
that's one of the first reactions I have
there's nothing I do there's no strength
I want to give up so fast you know at
some level yeah like you know I'm a
little combative in meetings at times
with clients where like I love
competition so much I would say being
competitive is probably as big of a deal
as it is but I would say that my
competition competitive gene goes 5 to 7
percent too far I would give a 5 to 7
percent of it because it's insane like
you know like you guys I mean you guys
know how I play basketball like like I
really am mad like I want to hurt people
like I want her people's feelings and
meetings like I literally like in
meetings will turn red my eyes will turn
red when somebody says something that I
think is really disrespectful to my
company and literally try to
historically clown them in the meeting
so that forever they're their exact
their contemporaries at that table I
literally want to say things that the
other people at the table on their side
tell to their grandchildren go I was
once in this meeting with this gallery
manager guy and he said the RIC was a
douchebag boss he said [ __ ] you like you
know like like I'm very into that I
wanna like like end the debate in the
room at that time whereas I could have
done it afterwards I've could have done
a little more politically correct but if
I get to that rogue tilt place
emotionally in a business meeting even
maybe the first time we ever meet I let
my competitive juices I can feel it it's
like that Incredible Hulk type stuff
like I can feel like I'll crap and about
to destroy this person's soul so that's
when one thing that I would give back 5
to 7 percent on a on a weakness that I'd
like to have a more of a strength on I'd
like to remember people's names better
actually that's very easy I spent an
enormous amount of time in our HR
software trying to make sure I know
everybody's names I you know and and
then the answer really is I have to
listen a little bit better in the
initial meeting like I'm like hey I'm
Gary
you need to say hi I'm India yeah but
like when she says hey she's India like
I'm not listening I'm already like until
I go stuff hey I'm Gary right I mean
listen right and so like not listening
when people say hello is a weakness
because if I actually listen I'll have a
50% chance of remembering their name
it's crazy
I will remember everything I'm very
visual like I could never get lost and
killer on directions I will bring up
stuff that happened between us like 15
years really like what like if I see it
it's on but if I hear it it's on but I
need to listen in the first place to
remember your name so remembering names
is something I'm passionately upset with
myself about like doc you could see I
knew Sheldon like I knew right away I
know what it's like I know with visually
I know he's like his profile side face
like hair like glasses like I know
exactly who he is but I sometimes I
struggle with is everything cool
question of the day what is your
favorite all-time Nintendo game favorite
all-time Nintendo game intro favorite
all-time antennal game give it to the
worst on camera just dude you're just
the worst
he's just the worst they're just the
worst you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them